almost all the coolest superheroes have
some kind of base of operations Superman
has his Fortress of Solitude the
Autobots have the Ark Ironman at one
point had a massive transforming Arctic
bunker and of course Batman has his
Batcave when my wife and I finally owned
our first home two years ago I finally
had the opportunity to make my own base
I'd always wanted a home gym that I
could combine with a home office
I'd always cramped hit it out with
awesome tech and training gear the plan
being to increase my productivity and
take my training to the next level but
then reality sunk in and I realized this
might not be quite possible to the
extent that I had in mind at least the
room that would become my Batcave the
bio lab was just big enough to fit a
single bed my budget wasn't endless and
we had a whole host of other projects to
do on the house which is why I had to
get practical do some research and find
the best gear and strategies I could use
to create something awesome and tailored
to my lifestyle in this video I'll be
sharing the best features of my own home
Batcave and how I've packed a lot of
Awesome into a small room
I'll also be looking at some cool
examples I've taken inspiration from and
the ideas that you guys have sent in the
mission to design the ultimate realistic
home Batcave a good starting point might
be to look at the real fictional Batcave
then and see what we can take from that
so Batman's space serves not only a
semi-firm to work in solve cases but
also somewhere for him to Train there's
a huge monument to his isolation and
introverted nature and I think that's
what appeals to a lot of us I actually
love spending time alone as it's one I
can work on my projects train research
and daydream I think more people could
benefit from more alone time actually
and having a Batcave is highly conducive
to that of course this is really
important if you run a home business but
even if you don't a space like this is
perfect for working on side projects for
learning these skills or just for
getting some R&R okay so this is the bio
lab knife on the wall normal as you can
see it's not a massive space or
definitely like a bigger one but let's
start in this corner and move our way
around to got a whole ton of books
graphic novels and my uber-cool Sonic
the Hedgehog
games collection here I've got my
biohacking shelf couple of supplements
in there that's cool Superman book stand
thing some boxes containing various junk
down here I have the oculus rift cause
some VR and I've stuck it on this star
frame head because I think it looks
really awesome even when I'm not
training got this holographic Iron Man
head here and a very cool star chart see
stuff like that I just find really
helpful to put me in the mood for
productivity it kind of sets a a
studious and scientific vibe in here
when I'm working so in his book deep
work Cal Newport describes something
called a eudaimonia machine and this is
basically an architectural ideal and the
idea is that it's a building designed to
coax the maximum amount of productivity
and creativity out of the individuals
who are working inside it and it's got
lots of different features but one of
the most interesting features is a kind
of like a library have to walk through
this hall of achievements and
inspirational items on the way in and
the idea is that by looking at these
examples of fantastic work and whatever
field you're in you'll feel inspired and
you'll have the sparks of creativity
flying and they'll help you to create
better work yourself and so that's what
I have tried to do in my office and so I
think everyone should do is fill it with
things that inspire your ideally things
that are somewhat related to your line
of work but it doesn't really matter it
can't just be anything that puts you in
this kind of inspired creative state of
mind so for me that means things like
the star chart globe it means things
like the Iron Man comics because you
know Iron Man to me is an inspiration
he's someone who you know got into got
me into business and the idea of running
a tech company and things like that as a
kid and Batman of course at the moment
I'm working on a book I'm a book
proposal for a fitness book and my kind
of pitch is that it's like real life
Batman files so just keeping it on the
desk
and to me in that kind of mood so it's
similar to what's known as priming in
psychology said priming is of course
when you expose yourself to a certain
stimuli in order to put yourself in the
correct state of mind is linked with
memory basically causes the correct
neurons to activate and fire and become
you know potentiated more likely to fire
because you're in that kind of brain
state so this is why for instance if you
want someone to answer a personality
test in a way that makes them come
across the song more cheery you might
put them in a good mood first and
similarly you can prime yourself to be
productive or you can prime yourself for
a good workout so before you go for a
workout you might watch command a for
instance or watch another film watching
the Dragon Ball Z that gets you psyched
yes the idea is that you're putting
yourself in that state of mind and if I
want to workout i watch commando if I
want to be productive I watch say the
trailer for limitless that just puts me
in this that just Prime's me for work
because that's the kind of productivity
and creativity and you know success and
achievement that I want to accomplish in
my day and the likewise just filling
your room with this kind of inspiring
stuff can make a huge difference and
that's why I highly recommend that you
fill your home office your home Batcave
with things that you find inspiring and
that's how it kind of ties into the idea
of Batman's memorabilia his kind of
achievements the t-rex the coin of
course you can find other places that
inspire you other places that could act
as your eudaimonia machine examples of
coffee shops I find them to be somehow
just conducive to productivity one of my
favorite places to work there was the
British Library in London are just full
of books and of sculptures it has a
giant statue of Newton outside and again
that just puts me in this state of mind
for productivity and creativity here is
where I get my work done this is where
the magic happens
so the moment I'm writing that's
actually the script for this video which
is meta so that's my kind of on the go
computer the Dell XPS 15 really great
machine for being able to be is a
workhorse computer lets me edit and
may computer games on the move wherever
I might be this is a 7-inch tiny laptop
you can do a lot with seven inches yeah
I've got my powerhouse computers is why
I use four serious video editing also
for the VR it's not actually a computer
it's a gaming laptop it's a couple years
old now it's got a GTX 1060 graphics
card which is more than enough to power
most things help us up headphones
noise-cancelling really helps with
productivity got my phone here plugged
in which means I can easily see it and
that's cause and I like to use various
software to mirror the screen on my
desktop I use this ultrawide monitor
ultra wide monsters of course more
immersive than smaller screens I've read
somewhere that they can increase your
productivity by 30% not sure if that's
true but I certainly find that having
that space to stretch out spread some
windows around to really helps I used to
use
and RGB strafe mechanical keyboard for
typing because a lot of people love
those mechanical switches I personally
found that I'm actually better and
quicker on a membrane keyboard that the
the travel is too far on those big
keyboards but each their own obviously
we're finding a good comfortable
keyboard is very important if you want
to increase your productivity and now on
to the training equipment the gym area
of the bio lab which is not terribly
tidy I must apologize for that but it's
because again I don't have enough space
at all so I've got my bench here which I
obviously use for curls you know
isolation curls and presses and flies
that kind of thing you'll see is it the
tricep dips
but the real star of the show and what
I'm giving most prominence to is just
the dip station here really simple piece
of equipment very cheap very easy to
store but it just does so much and you
know when Iced not in the user can
easily be tucked away in the side mat
let's put out those tonnes of dumbbells
a bit better
I've also got to gymnastic rings hang
from there you do a video on gymnastics
rings basically if you're thinking of
buying TRX then gymnastic rings very
much cheaper alternative which actually
do more they're more versatile so
something you can do with this setup is
RTA push-ups RTO standing four rings
turned outwards it's basically means of
your palms and a kind of supper nated
underhand grip as you're doing your
push-ups and what this does is it builds
the straight arm strength it builds the
the elbow resiliency don't get elbow
tendonitis etc and it's perfect for
building up to moves like the planche
the most important thing about having a
home gym and equipment in your home gym
is not so much the fact that you can
train at home and do full workouts at
home but also just the fact that you can
get lots of smaller workouts called
greasing the groove we're just
practicing skill so every time I go past
this room toilet I might pop in do some
dips do some planche training do some
RTA push-ups and what that's doing is
allowing me to not only be training and
moving when I'm working out but also
throughout the day it's not enough to
have a completely static lifestyle been
a couple of times a week take an hour
out to do exercise you need to be
constantly moving here we have a hand
dynamometer now this is a cool device
that lets you test your grip strength
it's not on there to test your grip
strength which it's not only useful for
seeing progress as you increase your
grip strength but also useful for
testing your recovery after workout I
also really like these mats on the
carpet bought them on Argos pretty cheap
they interlink and they just make the
space feel a bit more like a home gym
rather than just you know a room with a
carpet and some weights dumped on it
also of course means you're not gonna
dent or damage your carpet with big
heavy weights
I've also got this piece of metal which
I use for overcoming isometrics just
trying to crush it which I have not
accomplished yet oh and a signed picture
of Arnie up here which would be awesome
except for the signatures faded kind see
it so chances are it's a fake but it's
still cool okay so that's the bio lab
now let's take a look at some of the
home batcaves home offices and home gyms
that you guys sent in so first we have
this awesome Batcave from J freedom
lover you can find him on Instagram
who's all about freedom of movement he's
also gotten himself some gymnastics
rings and he's built a makeshift
standing desk from what I can tell he's
left a stick and some push ups downs
which I also use on the floor as
reminders to move this is what I was
talking about fantastic just for keeping
you active keeping you mobile and
avoiding yourself just becoming seized
up and adapted to sitting this is a
really great idea there's also a
Japanese futon a very minimal design and
it somehow feels very zen in this room
now when he also has a whole shelf of
supplements for biohacking another
wicked one comes from Greg whose primary
inspiration seems to be Sherlock Holmes
rather than Batman he has a really
decent amount of space to work with here
and an unreal amount of desk space I'm a
massive fan of the astronomical images
and the whiteboard which creates a very
studious mood coolest of all maybe is
that he has a 3d printer that uses to
make his own sculptures including a DNA
model I'm totally inspired to do
something similar to this
Jimmy has a simile boss space and
perhaps one of the most inventive
choices here was to turn the squat rack
into a standing desk that's a brilliant
use of space and it's a really good idea
Jimmy has multiple bags to here two
dumbbell rack which is very high on my
wish list and insane amount of plates
bars and equipment he's got loads of
space and he's absolutely maxed it out
with more training options and you're
likely even to see in a commercial gym
cinimon Stefanski so if i have said that
wrong keeps it simple here with a classy
desk and a pull-up bar directly above
dip bars
that's equipment for a whole bodyweight
training regime in a single spot
finally Levante also shared his home
office come Jim come bedroom making
maximum use of the space he has a sweet
anime collection some grip trainers
which I approve of ankle and wrist
weights a jump rope and some weights all
great examples of training equipment
that offer a lot of potential without
taking up a ton of space like I say
there's lots lots more that we could do
and if you look at things like MTV Cribs
you can get some really awesome
inspiration but obviously if you're a
bit more limited to space and for money
it's all about finding those few items
that are going to create a really
inspiring space and allow you to train
the way you want to train one last thing
I've learned though is if you are pushed
for budget in space don't try and overdo
it don't track crammed in too much
instead cut it back have it more minimal
take away all the stuff you don't need
and what you're left with will be a of a
higher average value more useful and be
much easier to use much easier to
appreciate because it's not so cluttered
that's one of the big mistakes I've made
in here and in future I might actually
get rid of my benchpress we'll move it
outside and use my home training to
focus more on the bodyweight stuff I'm
gonna be making a new office soon as I
move out of this one and if you guys
want to be involved in that video then
please send me more of your photos and
more of your videos and thanks so much
to all you guys who did contribute he
did chip in really appreciate it and
actually all of the comments you make
and all of the interactions I really
appreciate those too
so hope you found it useful an
interesting guy something a bit too
different here I've got lots more of
usual stuff on the way so don't worry oh
I've got a video looking at Bruce Lee
and how much of what he did was a myth
versus reality I've got a video on how
one might train actually like Batman so
if you enjoyed this one a Batman and
that would be cool got one on
accelerated learning and using the web
to gain more knowledge lots lots more
stuff gonna be looking at intermittent
fasting which I've been experimenting
with TIFF that all sounds good then
please leave a like please subscribe
share this video around all those things
helped me immensely thanks so much for
watching
and I'll see you next time bye for now